Texas held its primary elections last
night believe it or not the midterm
elections are now a mere eight months
from now Democrats are looking to make
gains everywhere they may but long term
the state of Texas is their top priority
and it's easy to see why Texas is a huge
state it's the biggest state that votes
Republican if Texas goes blue goes
Democrat it's over Republicans cannot
win a presidential election without
Texas America would then be a one-party
state for a generation at least and
maybe longer given the modern laughs
growing intolerance for anything that
resembles public dissent so with the
stakes so high and they are what
wouldn't Democrats do in order to win
why wouldn't they encourage non-citizens
to vote of course they're already doing
that explicitly in other states in Texas
it would make all the difference
Texas has the second highest percentage
of non-citizens in America after
California there are more than 3 million
non-citizens in the state overall
for perspective Hillary Clinton lost
Texas by only 800,000 vote so you do the
math the temptation is there it's
overwhelming so what actually stops
non-citizens from voting in Texas good
question
not much registration in that state is
conducted on the honor system as it is
in many states most the only way that
you are outed as a non citizen voter in
Texas is when you decide to admit that
you are Texas just assumes that all
voters are telling the truth
imagine if jewelry stores had the same
policy and they assumed that nobody
would ever consider stealing a necklace
that's crazy
well actions are more important than
necklaces but for some reason we don't
act that way in most states according to
the Texas Attorney General Ken Paxton
there is already ample evidence of
widespread illegal voting in Texas the
state just investigated four of its 254
counties and 165 unlawfully registered
non-citizens who'd been removed from the
voter rolls those non-citizens had cast
more than a hundred illegal votes before
they were caught which kind of makes you
wonder what's happening in the state's
other 250 counties we don't know we can
guess is you even mentioned the
possibility of illegal voting and left
tens well that's not real it's not even
possible of course they know better
because again it's happening they're
lying because voter fraud benefits them
this is what foreign interference
actually looks like in an election
Democrats are openly pushing it when
they aren't making it easier for illegal
immigrants to register to vote they are
fighting efforts to identify fraudulent
voters then they're demanding outright
amnesty would make the whole scheme
legal if it passed Republicans are
helping them with that for some reason a
brand new electorate from a different
foreign country that's what they want
Vladimir Putin was never that ambitious
by the way Jay Christian Adams is
president and general counsel of the
Public Interest Legal Foundation his
organization has been trying to obtain
voter role information from two of the
largest counties in Texas in an effort
to expose illegal registrations he joins
us tonight Christian thanks for coming
out Tucker so when you hear people say
this doesn't happen I mean there's so
many questions we know what happens the
real question is why aren't states why
is in Texas specifically doing anything
to prevent non-citizens from registering
well there's a lot of reasons sometimes
the left gets involved in litigation
they try to stop us from doing anything
there's a trial taking place in Kansas
right now because Kansas tried to do
something and the ACLU and a whole bunch
of international law firms dexhart big
huge law Eckert's Deckard is I would
Deckard price inroads try to abet
illegal voting well that's what they're
doing they're attacking the state of
Kansas citizenship verification look
Tucker Americans should be electing
American officials not foreigners in
Texas we asked for the voter roll
cancellations of non-citizens in Harris
County which is Houston and Barrett
County which is San Antonio right we
have a right to that information under
federal law those two counties are
stonewalling us and not letting us see
the data where's the Attorney General of
Texas Attorney General Texas Ken Paxton
is doing a great job on this because let
me tell you the problem is worse than
you just intro'd it's much worse than
that they're finding in Texas
non-citizens on the rolls across the
state and they're doing it in a way that
very few states are doing most states
have the honor system you check a box
you say you're citizen you're on the
rolls period no further investigation I
don't understand we've spent the last
two years embroiled in a scandal that
has basically stopped normal work and
Washington and it surrounds the idea of
foreign interference in American
elections here you have actual
documented evidence that foreign
citizens are affecting election outcomes
they're voting the most sacred thing
citizens do and the left says yet we
want more of that how does that work
well because they like it that's why it
works is because they enjoy how
foreigners are voting and so they hide
the ball they lie they don't tell the
truth about the extent of the problem
they try to prevent us from figuring out
how bad the problem really is and so
that's what the left that is so cynical
it's hard to be cynical as I am it's
hard to believe that that's actually
happening but it is so but my question
is Illinois is a democratic state it's
got a fake Republican governor but Texas
has a real Republican governor and so
among the Republican for now that'll
change soon if they don't get this under
control so why doesn't the legislature
pass a law saying you have to show that
you're a citizen before you register
well they may well do that in Texas it's
called documentary proof of citizenship
that's what Kansas did that's why Eckert
is suing Kansas along with the ACLU
anybody who tries to do something about
this whether it's my organization we
have a case in Starr County the ACR you
where we're getting non citizen records
in this tiny little border County
anybody who tries to do something about
this is attacked by the left by big mud
on what grabbing look I know that the
truth is they want voter fraud because
it gives them power and that's all they
care about I get that but what's the
pretext like what's their excuse for
preventing citizenship verifications
same one that the Oakland mayor said
it's racist if you attempt to verify
citizenship you're discriminating
against Hispanics that's in the
pleadings and these days whose vote gets
diluted by this African Americans who've
been here for hundreds of years and if
anybody they have a right to
representation and their vote is
becoming irrelevant because of this does
the Congressional Black Caucus ever
speak up about them no and that's what's
happening in Los Angeles City Council's
a matter of fact because of non citizens
being counted in Los Angeles
african-americans do not have as many
seats in because of non citizen
Hispanics being countered lost I hope
someone speaks up because it needs it
Thank You prision great to see you you
too Tucker